[Music]
rivera's friends and family honor her
on what would have been her 34th
birthday i don't believe in coincidences
i don't mean i feel like our steps are
already ordered and
i believe that your ryan path was
probably how it was supposed to go do
you believe that absolutely
on tuesday the late actress's ex-husband
and the father of her child ryan dorsey
posted this pic with naya and their son
josie
ryan captioned the snap quote just as
surreal as it is real that you're gone
if that makes sense but none of this
still makes any sense
34. i could just hear you saying ah i'm
old af
now huh rest easy old lady every path
and every uh mistake and up and down and
in between
in my entire life i feel like it's
already been you know planned out for me
nya's younger sister nakayla also paid
tribute on instagram
writing quote happy birthday naya thank
you for choosing me to be your little
sis
i love you forever and always
the actress was pronounced dead in july
2020 after her body was recovered five
days after she went missing
following a boat ride with her
five-year-old son at lake pairu in
ventura county california
there are a lot of currents on the lake
the idea of
perhaps being that the boat started
drifting it was unanchored
and that she mustered enough energy to
get her son back onto the boat
but not enough to save herself heather
morris chris colfer amber riley
and many more of her former glee
co-stars took to social media to pay
honor to her too
can i sail through the changing tides
can i handle the seasons
of my life heather who played naya's
on-screen girlfriend
britney s pierce posted this black and
white shot
wishing her angel a happy birthday
adding i can't write a sappy monologue
because it's just too hard but i love
you
and i can't describe how much i miss you
chris
shared this pic writing miss you as for
amber
she said she spent the day doing the
things that naya loved
most quote listening to amy winehouse
sipping wine and
eating a very fancy charcuterie kevin
mchale shared a party pic
and joked that quote no one else could
get us to be this messy in public
cord overstreet reposted kevin's post to
his insta story writing we sure do miss
you a lot down here
harry shume jr echoed that statement
sharing this image alongside the caption
what i imagine you doing up there right
now shine in brighter than a star
happy birthday baby girl we miss you
darren chris posted
this pic of nia on set while jenna
ushkowitz shared
this snap on her story i love you
in the morning it's the afternoon
you know i'm a mom now and i you know
what i love more than acting
is being josie's mom so i want to be
here for him and i don't want to miss
anything a source told et last month
that ryan and nia's families worked
together to make sure josie's christmas
was
extra special this year as it was his
first holiday without his mom
what's the greatest thing about being a
mom everything i mean absolutely
everything you know
it's very early mornings but i am so
excited
every morning it's like christmas
[Music]